- Never gave up.
- We didn't give up.
- Continued to move forward.
- Never ever ever give up.
- Never give up.
- Hello Believe nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how to never give up.
And as always guys as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please write it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it as well,
so others could be inspired.
And when you write something down,
you're much more likely to
remember it, so it helps you too.
(slow music)
- Essentially and I would
say this to anybody,
is that you know it's really,
it's easy to embrace hopelessness
when things seem insurmountable.
And yet, it's actually
just a matter of time
until all of the elements come together
for things to be alright.
I mean, I believe that,
most difficult situations
will resolve themselves
if you are persistent
and if you don't give up entirely.
And that's what I never
did, I never gave up.
- We were forced in the beginning.
I wish I could say we were geniuses
and say we're going to
start our own company.
That's not what happened.
In the beginning we went
to every single label
and every single label
shut they door on us.
The genius thing that we
did was we didn't give up.
We didn't say, because
these guys, we used that
what do they know approach.
We didn't give up at that point.
I think that was the genius thing we did.
We started selling our own CDs
and we built our own buzz and then
the record company came back to us.
So now we had a different negotiation.
It wasn't the same artist
label relationship.
Now we retain ownership
in our own company.
And it was the best thing for us.
- [Stephen] The decline in my health
was this dark reminder
that time was against me.
Yet despite the pressures in my family,
I was determined to realize
a life long ambition,
by writing a popular book about
how the universe had begun.
I wanted the book to be read by millions
of people around the world,
like the best selling airport novel.
- I did not think it would work.
I did not think it would work
because basically if you look at all
the other books in airports,
there are none like that, you know?
- [Stephen] However, I felt sure
that the mass market would want to know
about how the universe began.
By 1984, I had completed
the first chapter.
I signed up with Peter and set to work
completing my first draft of my book.
I tried to simplify the physics
as best I could and by the end
I was pleased and felt it
was in really good shape.
But Peter wasn't convinced.
- I was pretty disappointed, yeah.
I thought this is going
to be really difficult.
- [Stephen] Lightning did indeed strike,
but not in the way that
Peter and I were hoping.
That summer I had taken
a break from rewriting,
to travel to Switzerland on holiday.
But while I was there, I
caught a chest infection
that developed into pneumonia
and quickly became very serious.
I was put into a drug induced coma
and onto a life support machine.
The doctors thought I was so far gone
they offered (mumbles)
to turn off the machine.
But she refused.
Finally, Shane insisted that
I was flown back to Cambridge.
The weeks of intensive care
were the darkest of my life.
I felt I had always
fought my illness so hard
that I was not prepared
to give in so easily.
Slowly the drugs began to
work and the infection passed.
But the surgeons had to perform
a tracheotomy to allow me to breathe,
which made a small
incision in my wind pipe
and connected me to a ventilator
via the hole in my throat.
As a result, I was now robbed
of the ability to talk.
I faced a life unable
to properly communicate.
All hopes of finishing my book
and perhaps even my
career, seemed to be over.
I had enough movement in my right hand
to be able to click the computer system
and write the words I wanted.
Finally I was free to communicate again.
I was keen to make up the lost time
that my illness had forced upon me.
I had a stack of notes from Peter Guzzardi
suggesting changes and
clarifications to my book.
But I needed practical help with
the rewrite at my end,
someone who could act
as a go between.
After months of work,
the rewrite was complete.
None of us really knew whether
the book would be liked and
would sell as we all hoped for.
All we could do now was give it a title,
A Brief History of Time,
send it off to the printers
and wait.
(fast paced music)
But to everyone's surprise,
the book sold copy after copy.
And very quickly book
shops were selling out.
- When it hit the best seller list,
you're obviously surprised.
It was a pleasant
surprise and it certainly
was a surprise I don't (mumbles),
maybe I'm wrong, we'll say
oh yes we knew all along
this was going to be a major hit.
- I had no expectations it would be
the number one best
selling book in the world.
I mean, not just here
but Germany, Slovenia,
France, Italy, everywhere in the world
there was the hope that someone
had found the mystery of life.
- And from them on it was just a race
to keep the book in print
and marching towards
a million copies sold.
- It was very gratifying.
In the 38 years that I've
been in this business,
I don't think I have ever had a book
that stayed at the top of
the best sell list that long.
- I was amazing at how well it did.
I think it worked, he inspired people.
He gave people some overall sense
of the birth of the universe.
And it made this subject become
a subject of conversation among
people in all walks of life.
- [News Reporter] (mumbles)
the Stephen Hawkings book,
The Brief History of Time, an unlikely
but successful publishing, phenomenal.
- [News Reporter 2] A Brief
History of Time has sold
about eight million copies.
- [News Reporter 3] A popular
book about his theories
is already topping the
American best sellers list.
- [News Reporter 4] The hugely successful,
A Brief History of Time
by Stephen Hawking.
- [Stephen] A Brief History of Time
stayed in the best seller
list for over four years
and entered into the
Guinness book of records
for dong so.
To date, over 10 million
copies had been sold worldwide.
Over the next few years,
a lot of fuss was made about my book.
I became famous nationally
and around the world
as it was translated into
40 different languages.
- One of the greatest pieces of advice
I've ever gotten in my
life was from my mom
when I was a little kid.
There was a kid who was
bugging me in school.
And she said, okay I'm going
to tell you what to do.
She said the kid's bugging you,
he puts his hands on you,
you pick up the nearest rock
or whatever you can get your hands on
and you lay him out.
(laughing)
Then I did.
And I felt better.
And it worked.
(laughing)
So for me, that was a great lesson
because someone had invaded my space,
invaded my being and was
doing something against
me that I didn't want to be done.
So I took control of the
situation and I ran with it.
And many years later after being
turned into a product by
a very huge corporation
that had their hands all over me
and I couldn't escape it.
I promised myself that I
would continue to move forward
and do my best not to compromise
in any way what so ever,
not allow any one to put their hands on me
and effect me in that way.
So that's the best advice
I think I could give,
is just to keep moving forward
and don't give a (beep)
about what anybody thinks.
Just keep moving forward and
do what you have to do for you.
- Practice faithful persistence
means never ever ever give up.
Chicken Soup for the Soul was
rejected by 144 publishers.
144 publishers said we
don't want to publish
a collection of short stories,
the title is stupid,
Chicken Soup for the Soul,
what does that mean?
People don't buy collections
of short stories,
there's never been successful
chain of doing that.
So literally we spent 14 months
trying to find a publisher.
And we go to New York with our agent
and eventually our agent gave us
the book back and said I can't sell this.
So we went to the National
Book Sellers Association
convention down in Anaheim.
We went from booth to booth
to booth for three days.
And there were 4000
publishers represented there.
And we go, would you publish our book,
would you publish our book,
would you publish our book?
And we got no no no no no.
It was late on the third day,
that a little publisher from Florida,
after we've gotten over 144 rejections,
said we'll read it.
And then we said, well how many copies
do you think we'll sell, after they said
yeah we'll buy it a couple weeks later,
they said we'll publish it.
And they said, maybe
20,000 if we're lucky.
And we said, our goal is to sell
a million and a half in a year and a half.
Now have you ever told someone your dream
and had them laugh out loud at you.
(laughing)
He laughed out loud.
Now if we had given up after
100 publishers had said no,
I wouldn't be standing here today.
It wouldn't have happened.
And so you've got to be
willing to persevere.
Because we didn't take no.
See when the world says no, you say next.
Let's practice that, if
i say no, you say ...
- [Audience] Next.
- Absolutely.
There's only five or six
billion people out there
you can go and ask, right?.
There's over 4000 publishers just here
in the state of California.
So what we have is this
endless possibility,
but you have to persevere.
It's as if the universe
tests our commitment.
And so today we have 147 titles in print,
we've sold over 115 million copies,
we're in 47 languages and over
a billion dollars worth of
Chicken Soup for the Soul
books have been sold worldwide.
So if you're willing to
decide what you want,
believe it's possible,
consciously envision the future,
feel the feelings of
what it would feel like
if you would achieve this goal.
You could have anything
and then you take action.
Both obvious actions and aspired action,
you can do anything.
- If you're convinced
that you're going to fail
or fall or get hurt, that
will come to fruition
because that's what you're visualizing.
I was willing to get hurt along the way,
but I didn't visualize myself
getting hurt along the way.
And I think that's what
stops a lot of people
and that's really what
separates a lot of people
from being world champions or from being
as good as they can
because they stop at some point
in saying, oh no I am not capable of this,
or I'll probably get hurt doing this.
And if you approach anything
with that hesitation,
you're going to fail.
I always approached it
like, this is going to work,
I'm going to figure this out,
even if it takes me hundreds of attempts.
The idea of falling, getting back up again
that didn't really bother me at all.
- Unfortunately there are people with
the talent that don't have the money.
I kind of look at it like if any of you
have seen Cool Run Ins,
when they try to raise
money to go above sand and all the people
that they approached just laughed at them.
And it's the same for us, you know,
when my dad would say,
my son's going to be
the first Platform one driver,
everyone kind of thought, yeah right.
But you know you kept
going and it happened,
we got there so never give up.
- It's Tyler and DJ Ski.
And that was the carnival.
- The carnival was tight.
- How do you feel?
It's the fourth one?
- Mhmm.
- Do you think that it would grow
to be something this massive?
- No we was going to cancel
it this year but we didn't.
We was literally like
(beep) it and then we did it
and then a lot of people came.
- Why were you going to cancel it?
- I don't know.
We couldn't find anyone to perform.
It was just such like a,
'cause we're specific
on who we wanted there,
things like that.
And we couldn't come up
with the perfect thing
and it was just a depressing time.
And we was about to say (beep) it,
until we was like (beep)
it, what are we doing?
Where's our spirit?
And we ran it back and it was our biggest,
we dummy doubled up since last year.
It was crazy.
- Good question.
At what age should one
give up on their dream?
Never.
(mumbles) said this, Henry Ford said this,
Rockefeller said this,
you're only as young
or as old as your dreams.
And as long as you still have dreams
and visions and goals,
they keep you young.
It's the most amazing darn thing.
One of the great stories is
the story of Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Once upon a time, there was
a little boy named Harland
and Harland was taught by his mother
a special recipe down
south in the United States,
on how to make chicken.
When he grew up he got a job as
a short order cook in a small cafe.
And he asked his boss if his boss
would be interested in
this chicken recipe.
And his boss said, sure throw it together,
see what the people say.
Turned out that everybody liked
this special chicken recipe with all
these secret herbs and spices.
Well for the rest of his career,
right up 'til he was 65 years old,
he either worked in little cafes
or sometimes he owned a little cafe.
When he was 65 he had a little cafe
and he was making his chicken
and he had people coming from
all around to eat his chicken.
And the highways
department built a highway
past his little restaurant,
his little chicken place
and put him out of business.
They cut off the road so
nobody could get to it.
About the same time he received
a social security check, his
first social security check
at the age of 65.
And he became angry.
He said, I'm 65 years
old but I'm not ready
to give up on my dreams.
What do I have to sell?
And he realized the one thing
that had kept him going all those years,
the main stay of his little career
was his mothers recipe of
17 or 18 herbs and spices.
So he put them together in little bags.
One bag per chicken.
And he put his pots and pans in
the back of his old car
and he started driving
up and down the Eastern seaboard,
going from cafe to cafe to cafe,
to ask them if they would
pay him five cents a bag
for his magical combination
of herbs and spices.
He called on more than 1000 restaurants,
sleeping in his car, week after week,
and finally he came across a
little restaurant in Toronto
that agreed to pay him five cents a bag,
for his herbs and spices.
This is back in the 60s.
And because of exchange controls,
they had to give the
money to the Red Cross.
That was the beginning of the
Kentucky Fried Chicken empire.
He began to sell this
recipe more and more,
people began to put it on their signs,
a major corporation came along
and said we could make
a real business of this.
So they embraced him,
they built the franchise
that made him one of the best
known people in the world.
When he died seven years later,
he was worth more than 50 million dollars,
because he never gave up on his dreams.
So I don't know if you're
65 and broke and living
in your car with pots
and pans with no money,
but wherever you are, you
never give up on your dreams.
- Stay in front of the competition,
because there's two ways in this industry.
You move it or it moves you.
And I've seen so many sad stories
across the decade where
chefs have just got lazy.
Got lazy, given up and lost
that hunger to be competitive,
because it's the best job in the world.
That's not really a job, it's a passion,
because when you're rubbing shoulders.
And here we are now, 10 years later,
and I've got a restaurant
next door to Jamie Oliver's
and we're both literally two meters apart.
Phenomenal chef ...
And we keep each other on our toes.
So that's exciting for me and that's been
the one key issue across the 10 years
of filming Kitchen Nightmares,
never ever ever give up.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think.
What was the biggest most important lesson
that you learned from this video
that you are going to apply immediately
to your life or your business.
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I'm also curious, what
are some of the strategies
that you use to never give up?
What do you want to add to this video
that might help other entrepreneurs
who are considering giving
up in their business?
Please leave it in the comments.
And finally I want to
give a quick shout out
to the Auckland Council Library.
Thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word
and having it in your library.
I really really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.